[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nouvelle semaine à
d'informations locales sur tv et
soixante dix huit bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal et les titres de ce lundi 4
décembre
il pourrait s'imposer comme une sérieuse
alternative au wifi le lit fille entre
dans une phase d'industrialisation
cette technologie développée par une
start-up yvelinoise permet de
transmettre des données via la lumière
led co inventé par soit au dessous qui
est notre invité les températures de
plus en plus fraîches avec le mois de
décembre qui débute c'est une période
sensible aussi sur les routes avec le
verglas la neige ou encore la luminosité
plus faible comment conduire là l'hiver
sans danger on en parle avec jean yves
petit directeur du comité des yvelines
de la sécurité routière
enfin c'est une première coignières
organisé samedi son marché noël un
événement et qui laissait à la part
belle aux producteurs de la ville nous
étions sur place on prend tout de suite
la direction d'el en cours pour ouvrir
ce journal une cérémonie a débuté il y à
peu bonsoir nicolas kirillovitch vous
êtes sur place à la mairie de la ville
la municipalité remet officiellement ce
soir des caméras piétons à ses policiers
municipaux c'est un nouvel outil pour
assurer la protection des agents
oui grégory c'est l'objectif principal
de ces caméras
elles sont cinq au total à équiper les
agents d'elancourt dès ce soir et ont
pour but donc de prévenir les
comportements qui peuvent être parfois
violents lors des interventions
elles peuvent aussi saveurs servir de
preuve dans le cadre d'une procédure
judiciaire classique ou permettre aussi
la formation des agents de la ville
évidemment ce système est très encadrées
et répondent à des règles strictes fils
est fixé par décret nous sommes
d'ailleurs avec le maire d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous pour préciser
l'ensemble de ces dispositions
monsieur le maire dit où est ce que
c'était nécessaire aujourd'hui à
elancourt d'avoir ces caméras piéton est
ce que ça répond à un problème
d'insécurité pour les agents municipaux
les policiers municipaux m'écouter
le monde bouge les technologies aussi
les moyens de sécurité aussi puisqu'on a
une police municipale quand même assez
importante de près de 30 personnes
aujourd'hui
e
[Musique]
être des amis allaient à voter juste de
la police nationale
mais bien sûr la vidéo envahi
la société et il n'est pas anormal que
bien entendu un métier aussi sensibles
que les policiers soient sur consterné
et est donc
c'est la mise à disposition d'une caméra
pour clarifie
pour enlever l'ambiguïté qu'il y a
quelques fois dans dans un conflit sur
l'interprétation des uns des autres et
quand ils y allaient justice qui me
semblait derrière moi oui c'est on sait
plus qui s'est dit on sait plus qui
s'est fait bon et qu'évidents que avec
une vidéo ça aide à objectiver une
situation conflictuelle et en fait à
rétablir la justice est à dire la vérité
de ce qui s'est passé
alors on sait que c'est que ces caméras
parfois peuvent peuvent prêter un peu à
la polémique sur le volet privé ou sur
l'utilisation faite de ses caméras après
coup sur les images qui sont qu'ils sont
filmés tout est très encadrée qu'est ce
que vous répondez du coup assez à ses
éventuelles critiques
donc c'est très encadré par la loi c'est
accessible d'abord en cas de bien sûr de
faits délictueux ces traités par la
justice
donc voilà c'est pas accessible à
n'importe qui donc c'est comme les
caméras que vous voyez dans les oiseaux
de caméras aujourd'hui elle encourt donc
cesser c'est un peu dans le même cadre
juridique et puis mais en même temps ça
ajoute
en tout cas la transparence sur une
intervention qui peut quelquefois être
un peu difficile un peu sensible un peu
conflictuelle même quelquefois même
physique thé vide en queue après
lorsqu'on a à juger des faits
personne ne s'y retrouve il suffit que
bien sûr le individus qui est à
l'origine de cette crise
nini tout et voilà donc on peut pas
mettre en cause
il ya des dégâts liés la justice c'est
aussi de dire la vérité sur sur sur une
crise sur un moment difficile et c'est
vrai que ces caméras sont une aide
considérable pour la justice alors
grégory vous l'avez compris ses caméras
c'est cinq au total 1 qui seront
effectives dès ce soir dans la brigade
de nuit et l'on courait dernière
précision les policiers devront prévenir
dans l'enregistrement d'un contrôle les
images seront accessibles aussi très de
façon très limitée pour certaines à
certains policiers et elles seront
supprimés au bout de six mois
l'expérimentation doit durer jusqu'en
juin 2018 pour ces cinq caméras piétons
et merci à vous nicolas est également à
patrick jacques de dixmude aux moyens
techniques à saint rémy les chevreuse
quatre listes seront eux en lice pour le
second tour des municipales le premier
tour c'était hier une tendance la maire
sortante divers-droite agathe becker
arrive dernière de ce premier tour avec
12 66% des suffrages est loin derrière
les 32 67% de la liste sans étiquette de
dominique bavoil en tête dans un
mouchoir de poche suivent le candidat
sans étiquette jean louis et binic et
celui à de la république en marche
dominique dufrasne une rencontre entre
chefs d'entreprise et des financeurs et
également c'est un homme également une
rencontre avec un député le député jean
noël barrot
c'était à vendredi à la cci à versailles
yvelines chambre de commerce et
d'industrie matinée d'échangés autour de
la question du financement des
entreprises le parlementaire a été
missionné avec l'entrepreneur a lissé
aguri par la ministre de l'économie et
des finances est le 10 décembre ils
doivent remettre leurs propositions en
vue du plan d'action pour soutenir la
croissance et la transformation des
entreprises
objectif de la rencontre donc recenser
les bonne idée d'associer effectivement
un chef d'entreprise avec un
parlementaire et en ce qui me concerne
je suis je ne suis pas issu directement
du monde de l'entreprise plutôt du monde
universitaire ça nous permet d'avoir un
regard assez neuf sur des problématiques
qui sont souvent traités au min
de l'économie et donc d'apporter des
idées neuves à sur ces sujets cette voie
tas de terrain et est essentiel parce
que bien souvent on a l'impression que
les projets de loi sont rédigées sans qu
on ait la possibilité de questionner
ceux qui sont désintéressés justement et
les entreprises en particulier et
devenir et d'avoir un échange entre le
député et les donc de députés qui est
chargée de cette mission
et puis les entreprises est pour moi
quelque chose d'essentiel
je vous en parlais dans les titres une
start-up yvelinoise oled comme développe
une nouvelle technologie le l'ifi permet
de se connecter à internet grâce à la
lumière
une innovation qui pourrait
prochainement et débarquer chez vous
nicolas d'andry est allé à découvrir le
lit fille dans les locaux de
l'entreprise au sein de l'iut de vélizy
imaginez une connexion à internet avec
de la lumière
eh bien ce n'est plus un rêve la société
oled comme l'a développée à partir de
recherches initiées au sein de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
vous pouvez vous connecter à internet
avec un modem bidirectionnelle donc dans
les deux sens ça fonctionne dans les
deux sens c'est la lumière visible qui
transmet le signal internet 2 du
lampadaire vert vers l'ordinateur à
travers un un petit type clé usb qu'on
n'a pas la longueur grâce à cela nous
avons une connectivité sans ondes
complètement sécurisé dans les bureaux
c'est à dire que le signal le traversant
pas les murs comme le wifi ça lui
confère des niveaux de sécurité
exceptionnelles howlett comme rentre
dans une nouvelle phase
l'industrialisation
à partir de cette technologie des
applications sont proposées notamment au
secteur hospitalier et du transport
on est aujourd'hui un pionnier mondial
de la technologie à une vingtaine de
brevets qui ont été déposées il est
temps à présent d'en faire des produits
commercialisables industrialisable afin
de créer un business pérenne pour la
société après des études d'ingénieur
bastien béchadergue s'est lancé dans un
projet de recherche sur le lit fille au
sein du laboratoire d'ingénierie des
systèmes de versailles aujourd'hui c'est
son premier jour de travail chez oled
comme pour la communication
pour les problèmes des technologies
radio qui arrive pas à satisfaire toute
la demande
on arrive tout à coup avec l'éclairage
c'est un côté un peu magique à
transmettre des données
j'étais vraiment enthousiasmé par cette
idée là prochain rendez vous important
le cs de las vegas du 9 au 12 janvier
pour présenter le premier produit
commercialisé de howlett comme
récompensé par deux prix internationaux
avec nous en plateau le co inventeur de
cette technologie l'ifi bonsoir soit
obsolète
vous êtes professeur de l'université
saint quentin de saint quentin en
yvelines vous avez fondé de cette start
up aux lettres comme qui développe et
commercialise le l'ifi à vous en êtes
aujourd'hui le président alors on l'a vu
un petit peu dans ce sujet mais pour
vulgariser le lit fit donc ça veut dire
light fidelity c'est donc utiliser la
lumière led pour transmettre des données
qu comment est ce possible
c'est un peu comme un jeu d'enfant quand
on faisait du morceau petit quand on
était petits on a allumé une torche pour
envoyer des sms sauf que la led et cette
capacité de pouvoir saluer cet humble
très très vite donc on va faire du morse
optique mais à des vitesses propre à
l'ordinateur des millions de fois par
seconde et donc transmettre des données
simplement en allumant est né un
éteignant très rapidement la lumière
vraiment comme du morse optique à très
haute vitesse en vous travaillez sur
cette technologie depuis 2005 mais
l'idée de transmettre des données par la
lumière ça remonte à beaucoup plus loin
alexander graham bell déjà faisait des
expérimentations sur ce sujet à la fin
du 19e siècle est tout à fait il
utilisait la lumière du soleil pour
envoyer des données a été d'ailleurs la
première méthode de communication sans
fil ça utiliser la lumière puis est
arrivée la radio maintenant la radio
étant saturé on a beaucoup beaucoup trop
de d'instruments donc on va aller vers
la lumière pour trouver des nouveaux
moyens nouveaux vecteurs de
communication et comment vous est venue
en 2005 cette idée c'est les travaux d
alexander graham bell qui vous avez
inspiré de continuer oui
développer ses recherches n'a incité
plus que je ne connaissais pas les
travaux de grabels dans l'idée était
venue avec les voitures les véhicules
qui commençaient à s'équiper en farlède
d'accord et on avait un premier projet à
l'université de faire communiquer des
véhicules entrent en utilisant les
phares à led donc les voitures pouvaient
se parler entre elles pour des raisons
de sécurité donc on disait on peut se
connecter à internet on pense tout
d'abord à cet usage
mais l'édifice sert aussi à bien
d'autres choses il ya de nombreuses
applications qui sont possibles grâce au
wifi tout à fait la première c'est par
exemple vous avez de la lumière partout
dans l'est dans les bâtiments donc on
peut utiliser cette lumière pour aider
les personnes à se guider
on expérimente avec le métro parisien la
ratp la possibilité de guider des
personnes aveugles dans le métro sur les
quais en utilisant la lumière et par
rapport au wifi l'on va dire les les
points qu'est ce que ça apporte de plus
le lycée des technologies
complémentaires le wifi existe le lift y
arrive ne va pas détrôner le wifi ils
vont cohabiter trouver chacun leur
espace pour s'exprimer les avantages du
lit fils et des débits qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 200 fois plus élevé que le wifi
et sera plus rapide et surtout il n'y a
pas d' onde radio donc tout pour les
personnes qui pensent que les ondes
radio c'est pas bon pour la santé
là il n'y a pas de gap à ce genre de
soucis alors vous avez travaillé avec
cette technologie avec de nombreuses
entreprises thales la sncf pour ne citer
qu'elles également le monde hospitalier
maintenant le défi on l'a vu dans le
reportage c'est de s'ouvrir peu à peu au
grand public c'est ça que vous avez vous
entré dans une phase d'industrialisation
finalement on passe à une phase
d'industrialisation parce qu'on a une
demande qui est croissante de jour en
jour mais mais passer d'un état
laboratoire à une production de masse
arrête pierre beaucoup de moyens et du
temps et donc on en est aujourd'hui si
au niveau de l'évolution de la
technologie qu'elles sont finalement les
difficultés c'est le coût de la
technologie haut et qui encore il faut
il faut réussir à abaisser le coût pour
que ça s'ouvre au grand public alors le
coup est lié aux quantités quantité crif
dans notre entité depuis les coûts
baissent mais pour avoir de la quantité
il faut préserver la qualité donc il
faut être capable de produire un gros
volume en préservant une certaine
qualité pour avoir
prix correct et toucher le marché ce qui
est toute une phase tout à fait normal
dans n'importe quelle industrie on en
est à ce niveau là aujourd'hui et sur le
calendrier vous avez déjà une idée de
quand ça pourra arriver pour le grand
public ont le grand public des produits
des premiers produits en 2018 et puis
alors qu'ils seront un peu cher et qui
petit à petit vont baisser au fur et à
mesure des années on est à la kadji on
parle déjà de la 5g l'idée c'est
peut-être ça aussi de se greffer on
parle de la 5g d'ici à 2020 c'est de se
greffer aussi sur ces nouvelles
technologies qui arrive un travail avec
la commission européenne effectivement
pour intégrer le lycée dans la salle
chez qui arrivent de manière à ce que
les gens puissent utiliser aussi bien
des ondes radio que de la lumière pour
toujours avoir plus de connexions
dernière chose il nous reste une minute
ça a été dit à la fin du sujet là vous
serez présent au consumer electronics
show le cms à las vegas ce sera début
janvier prochain c'est cette fois là
l'idée de cette présence quelle est
l'idée derrière alors justement on va
présenter notre premier produit grand
public pour lequel on a eu deux prix aux
ces us de las vegas et ce cas une
première un premier startup française de
priaulx ce fameux consumer electronic
show c'est quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel
merci à vous saute haut je le rappelle
président ado l'aide comme vous êtes le
co inventeur de cette technologie a dû
l'ifi et pour plus d'informations sur
votre start up vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
elle est faite se rapproche et sous le
sapin des cadeaux de noël pour tous
c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé le
secours populaire à maurepas ce week-end
l'association organisait des récoltes de
jouets en partenariat avec l' enseigne
picwic
nicolas landry et les arrête pas de
traîneau pour le père noël cette année à
maurepas
mais des palettes remplie de cadeaux
tout de même le secours populaire il
enseigne picwic ont uni leurs forces ce
week-end pour gâter des enfants
défavorisés les enfants défavorisés en
besoin de jouets neufs ils ont droit
comme tous les enfants du monde avoir
déjoué de bonne qualité et on remercie
énormément tous les clients du magasin
qui qui nous ont aidés dans cette
démarche
on vend du jouet et je crois qu'on vend
un peu de rêve aussi et que là on est
complètement dans la lignée de ce que de
2,9 métier à la base tout le monde n'a
pas forcément les
l'argent la facilité pouvoir s'acheter
des jouets si nous on peut aider à ce
niveau là on en est ravi des dvd des
poupées déluge ou encore des toupies
tous les cadeaux sont les bienvenus
l'équipe du secours populaire compte sur
la solidarité et la générosité des
acheteurs les chansons nouvelles
beaucoup donnent de très beaux jouets et
on est toujours étonné la quantité de
vous et on a fait 50 5 à 10 en deux
jours ce qui est une belle performance
l'objectif offrir un peu de magie à une
cinquantaine d'enfants pour noël une
démarche que l'enseigne renouvelle leur
défaite depuis trois ans on a remises
5100 euros de jouer ce qui représentait
à peu près 700 pièces de jouer pas mal
de jeux vidéo aussi et beaucoup de
mesure crée le père noël passera avec un
peu d'avancé les cadeaux récoltés lors
de ce week end seront remis aux enfants
le 21 décembre et on reparlera dans un
instant des fêtes avec une ville de
saint quentin en yvelines à qui
organisait ce week-end son premier
marché de noël début début du mois de
décembre vous l'avez constaté des
températures qui chutent la semaine
dernière par exemple la neige est tombée
sur les yvelines en cette période sur
les routes il convient d'adopter la plus
grande vigilance bonsoir jean yves petit
soin vous êtes le directeur de
l'association prévention routière donc
le comité des yvelines de l'association
prévention routière
l'hiver c'est une période de grand
danger sur les routes
alors oui l'hiver est une période de
danger sur les routes l'était aussi
d'ailleurs mais enfin l'hiver de danger
pas pour les mêmes raisons la principale
raison comme vous l'avez dit ce sont les
intempéries bien sûr mais aussi le fait
que en hiver il fait nuit beaucoup plus
tôt donc aux heures de pointe le matin
et le soir il fait nuit
ça compte pas lever le matin et fait
nuit quand on rentre il fait nuit donc
ça va augmenter les risques éminemment
sur les routes
est ce que c'est une période où il ya
plus d'accidents que qu'à l'accoutumée
que le reste de l'année
on constate enfin les services de l'état
un constate qu'il ya plus d'accidents en
particulier au moment où on bascule de
leurs de l'heure d'été à l'heure d'hiver
d'accord parce que du jour au lendemain
on se retrouve comme jeudi à l'instant
de nuit aux heures de pointe alors que
la veille les jours encore
donc les gens ont un petit temps pour
s'habituer à ce changement
mais alors les les gens sont malgré tout
plus prudents quand le temps est mauvais
en général puisqu'ils savent que le
temps est mauvais je parle du vraiment
mauvais temps koala les chutes de grêle
à la grosse neige le verglas
donc comme les gens sont plus prudents
ils vont moins vite ils font plus
attention et il ya beaucoup moins de
monde sur la voie publique en
particulier des piétons les vélos évite
de sortir
vous disiez il ya des causes
météorologique est ce que le premier
réflexe à adopter finalement c'est pas
de ceux de comment dire de s'informer de
regarder les prévisions avant de partir
dimanche soir au 16 rue oui bien sûr
regardez les prévisions météo qui sont
maintenant quand même fiable et on a ça
partout sur son smartphone partout oui
s'informer sur les conditions météo il
ya quelques jours
hier ou avant-hier il ya eu tout début
de pluies verglaçantes dans le
département là il valait mieux être
prudent quand même et s'informer car
outre la baisse des températures vous
les 10 principales causes aussi la
luminosité qui réduit qui se réduit les
journées sont plus courtes les temps
d'éclairage donc réduit que ce soit pour
les véhicules les cyclistes les piétons
il faut aussi une vigilance sur sur la
visibilité est revu ses produits de tous
c'est vraiment le leitmotiv
il faut avoir conscience surtout quand
on est piéton ou cycliste qu'on n'est
pas bien vue de nuit même en ville
l'éclairage public et pas toujours
parfait donc on est on est pas bien vu
même si soi même on est jeune piéton ou
cycliste et qu'on se dit mais moi je
vois bien si on a face à soi un
automobiliste qui à 81 85 ans lui voit
beaucoup moins bien bien sûr donc et 6
km un gilet réfléchissant par exemple il
ya
leur façon pour les cyclistes bien sûr
mais déjà s'assurer que le vélo est
conforme à la réglementation c'est à
dire avec des feux devant derrière et
des catadioptres il ya beaucoup de vélo
qui n'en n'ont pas et puis s'équiper
avec un gilet réfléchissant même si en
ville ce n'est pas obligatoire et pour
les véhicules bien vérifier aussi que
les deux feux fonctionnent on peut être
pris pour un cyclomoteur assez
facilement soluble veut s'assurer
mais ce alors ça c'est le contrôle
technique ou celle d'une façon générale
l'état technique des véhicules
oui s'assurer que tous les feux
fonctionnent bien sûr est que les les
feux sont propres alors une vigilance à
avoir également sur les pneus qui
souffrent du froid plus la température
est basse plus la pression mesurée sera
faible et du coup est-ce que vous
conseiller de surgonflé légèrement les
pneus il est plutôt conseillé
c'est du moins ce que préconisent les
professionnels du pneu d'adopter des
pneus hiver qui est
efficace des 7 degrés bon maintenant
avoir des des pneus ici en région
parisienne en particulier où il ya quand
même pas pour l'instant des d'effroi des
froids polaires avoir des pneus en bon
état et bien gonflé c'est déjà quand
même c'est déjà perd même pas mal on
imagine aussi on va aller très vite ce
qui nous reste une minute bien adapter
sa vitesse sa vitesse pardon être
vigilant sur les distances de sécurité
peut-être un peu plus vivant qu'à
l'accoutumée il ya aussi peut-être aussi
le matériel
il faut avoir un matériel adapté en
voiture peut-être
avoir des choses en plus par rapport au
reste de l'année dans sa voiture ont
coûté je vois pop d'une couverture de
survie quand on voyage sur les baies
mais surtout ce que vous avez dit est
important les distances de sécurité il
est évident que la nuit ou par
intempéries pluie neige brouillard
il faut augmenter les distances de
sécurité la distance de sécurité
réglementaires du code de la route ces
deux secondes entre deux véhicules qui
suivent eh bien il est prudent de
l'augmenter dans la visibilité est
mauvaise et aussi tenir compte quand on
roule sur une départementale par exemple
la nuit qu'on apprécie beaucoup moins
bien le relief et les distances
donc quand on est des feux en face de
soi savoir à quelle distance et
l'aboyeur c'est pas facile
derniers conseils peut-être cela semble
évident mais une piqûre de rappel ne
fait pas de mal ne pas dépasser les
engins de service hivernal ceux qui vont
par exemple des salles et la fin et qui
vont mettre du sel sur la route ça il
faut rester derrière il faut pas il faut
aller déjà son bilan mais il faut quand
même les doubler si c'est bon c'est pas
interdit de les doubler mais enfin en
prudence évidemment on va pas rester à
10 à l'heure pendant pendant longtemps
merci jean yves petit d'avoir été avec
nous je vous en prie je l'appelle
directeur du comité des yvelines de
l'association prévention routière
merci merci à vous et bientôt les fêtes
donc et les préparatifs qui vont avec
cadeaux à 0 pas ce week-end marquait le
top départ des marchés noël elancourt
montigny le bretonneux et nouvelle venue
dans cette catégorie c'est la ville de
coignières est la commune organisé son
premier événement du genre camille
lambert et nicolas landry décorations
pour le sapin ou la maison produits du
terroir et animations de doute c'est la
recette est respectée pour ce premier
marché de noël avec un ingrédient locale
plus de la moitié des exposants sont de
coignières nous avons
dix huit exposants dont huit
professionnels et les autres sont des
gens de coignières qui sont là aussi
pour montrer leur créativité et a
vraiment de très belles choses aussi
bien au niveau tricot au niveau
décoration de noël haut niveau je crois
pas des pis aussi voilà une première
pour beaucoup de ces artisans comme
lionel qui fait découvrir sa production
de pommes
je suis amateur vraiment de foot y est
ancien et de pommes notamment pour
réaliser du cidre à l'origine c'est
vraiment une passion d'enfance c'est
l'occasion aujourd'hui avec ce marché
noël de remettre au goût du jour ses
fruits anciens parce que c'est aussi un
verger conservatoire que j'ai créé que
nous avons également développé sur la
ville des idées pour les repas de fête
et aussi pour le père noël afin de
préparer leur liste les habitants ont
répondu présent à cette première édition
j'adorais les pommes là bas où on
fabrique et les jus les compotes de
pommes de poires à chaud ça vraiment
sympa très intéressant sacré de
l'ambiance ça permet de rencontrer des
gens c'est vivant j'espère que ça se
reproduira les butins hante encore du
pain sur la planche pour que tout soit
prêt le 24 décembre et accueillir petit
papa noël quand il descendra du site
[Musique]
deux jours et vous avez sans doute
reconnu l'air de être sinon aussi du
sport horizon 2024 c'est le nom de cette
grande compétition des scream qui se
tenait hier au gymnase maurice baquet à
guyancourt trente trois athlètes étaient
de la partie ce sont de futurs champions
de la discipline retour sur la
compétition nicolas landry et michael et
demi d'euros ils ont entre 13 et 14 ans
ils seront peut-être aux jeux olympiques
de paris en 2024 pour les aider à
progresser le club de gueugnon co
organisait ce dimanche 3 dès son origine
as more is back un tournoi baptisé
horizon 2024 au total 33 jeunes avec des
rêves plein la tête ont participé à ce
rendez vous j'aimerais bien y aller et
j'aimerais bien aussi gagner aussi mais
d'abord faut gagner cette compétition
j'aurai moins de chance en or et en 2024
cette compétition qualificative pour les
championnats de france a surtout permis
à ces jeunes pépites venues de toute
l'île de france de peaufiner leurs
techniques de combat hausse à savoir
quand est-ce que l'adversaire va faire
basculer déjà ce serait bien et après on
va attaquer attaquer au bon moment
attaqué trop tôt je m'adapte ans en
fonction de ce qu'ils font s'ils vont
plus faire des attaques j'aime et à la
défense circule pas j'allais à l'attaqué
ce dimanche chaque participant a pu
prendre part une dizaine de combats mais
le chemin vers une médaille d'or aux
jeux olympiques est encore long selon
les coachs et a quand même beaucoup de
travail on verra s'ils arrivent à a
progressé à continuer
alors progression tout au long de leur
vie d'escrimeur et puis pour les
accompagner il faut voir là actuellement
c'est difficile à dire parce que c'est
quand on est quand même assez loin mais
on éduque travail à faire c'est sûr et
il ya du potentiel aussi d'autres
tournois seront organisés avec but en
cours d'ici 2024 pour former cette
nouvelle génération la mairie le club
local ont signé un partenariat avant de
refermer ce journal c'est le dernier
représentant des yvelines dans la
compétition où il s'est qualifié pour
les 32e de finale de la coupe de france
de football est la victoire samedi à
domicile face à un club guyanais
l'étoile matoury 2 buts à 1
prochaine adversaire connu ce soir avec
le tirage au sort et ce pourrait être
une équipe de ligue 1 rencontres au
programme en janvier prochain
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal une
édition et des reportages à revoir sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv et 78 très bonne semaine à
tous
[Musique]